[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: In
yesterday's keynote,
we heard all about
modernization with Google Cloud.
Today's keynote took
us a step further,
focusing on infrastructure,
insight, and innovation.
Director of Cloud AI Strategy
and Operations, Tracy Frey
is here with us to tell us more.
Tracy, give us the highlights
from today's keynote.
TRACY FREY: So I think one
of the most exciting things,
is that we're really starting
to see how customers are
leveraging the Cloud
and building Cloud
strategy no matter
where they're starting.
Whether that's starting
from on prem, hybrid,
all of these things
are now available.
And we as an overall
Cloud organization
have been working really
hard to make it incredibly
easy for customers to start
where they are and leverage
our products and
services to really update
their infrastructure and drive
innovation for their companies.
And that was really
clear to me today,
and it was really exciting
to see it all come together.
SPEAKER 2: Now, AI is
embedded in everything we do.
What are you most excited
for about AI and Google Cloud
and other parts of Google?
TRACY FREY: You know, it's a
little bit of a similar answer,
to be honest.
So over the last
year and a half,
I've spoken with
hundreds of customers.
And everybody is really
excited about AI.
But a lot of organizations
don't know what that means.
And they don't know
how AI can impact
their business and
the business problems
that they're facing today.
And we've been working
really hard to create
a set of products and
solutions and services that
can help address
some of those mission
critical problems very
easily for customers.
And so I'm really excited
to see some of those
examples really start
to come to light.
Things like Salesforce
working with Hulu
on our contact center,
our natural language
processes being a part
of the Einstein Bot.
Things like what Baker Hughes
GE is doing with our Cloud AI
platform.
It's really exciting to see
these tactical examples of how
AI can impact an enterprise.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
We saw a lot of great demos
showing Google Cloud products
at work.
How are these new products
helping our customers
manage data reliably
and securely,
so they can modernize scale
and can really be successful?
TRACY FREY: Well,
if you look at what
we saw in the smart
analytics demo,
you could really see the
end-to-end experience
for customers.
And that's a lot of
where the pain has been.
So for example, in
Cloud AI, we own
Kaggle, which is
the world's largest
community of data scientists.
And they often joke that
data scientists will
say that 90% of the
pain in machine learning
is cleaning the data
and 10% is complaining
about cleaning the data.
And that is an
experience that I think
anybody who has worked
to extract insights
from their data can relate to.
Because it can be
extraordinarily painful.
And when you see all
of the products that
are coming together across
our smart analytics platform,
everything from BigQuery
and Data Fusion, all
of those pieces,
AutoML Tables, you
can start to see
how easy it can be
for customers to extract those
insights at scale very quickly.
SPEAKER 2: And speaking of these
features that help our data
analytics workflows, we saw
some great demos highlighting
some new features, like Cloud
Data Fusion, BigQuery BI
Engine and AutoML Tables.
How can developers,
scientists, and analysts
apply these to support
their hybrid workloads?
TRACY FREY: So I can speak
specifically to AutoML Tables,
because that's the product
that our team works on.
And one of the things
that I have really
loved about the AutoML
suite is that it really
doesn't require machine
learning expertise to use it.
And at the same time, it's an
extraordinarily helpful tool
for people who are machine
learning experts and builders.
And it has the
ability to stretch
across those
populations and make
it really useful for anybody.
We have heard over and over
that structured data is
a real challenge for customers.
And so being able to
leverage something
like AutoML Tables,
where customers
can start to piece together
information from disparate data
sets, build them all together,
allow machine learning models
to be created for you
through the AutoML tool,
without having to
write any code.
It just is really exciting
to see what that can do.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
And can you give us some
examples from today's keynote
of how our viewers
will be able to use
machine learning and Google AI?
Especially those in
companies just starting out
who may not already have
a lot of ML experience.
TRACY FREY: Yeah, absolutely.
So there are a couple
problems that we've
heard from customers
that are really
common across the landscape
of enterprise customers.
A top one is in contact
centers and customer service.
And this is a challenge that
almost every organization
I've spoken with faces
in some form or fashion.
Our AI has worked really hard
to enhance the human agents who
are working in contact
centers, give them
everything they need at
their fingertips in a really
efficient and beautiful way.
And what we've done
there is integrate
our AI with the key players
in the contact center space
so that it doesn't require
customers to do a full rip
and replace on hardware
they've already purchased.
And so that's a very
easy way to get started.
We've also heard from
almost every customer
that another area they really
struggle with is dark data.
And that exists
in documents that
are both physical documents,
digital documents.
That challenge, if you think
about a paper that you read
or a PDF where you
have graphs and tables
and all kinds of information--
and the ability to actually
be able to extract those pieces,
those components using AI,
make sense of them, and
then pull insights out
of that through our
document understanding AI,
we really believe is going to
help customers gain efficiency
and information much faster.
And that's another
way that I think
would be great for
customers to get
started that we've seen today.
SPEAKER 2: Now,
many people may know
that we build AI into
a lot of our products,
like G Suite, Google Maps.
How can our customers
use those tools
to build their innovative
features into their own tools
and products?
TRACY FREY: So we offer
a range of products.
Everywhere from pre-trained
APIs to AutoMLs,
where you can customize to
meet your specific needs,
through to our
Cloud AI platform,
where you can very easily
build your own machine
learning models if you
have that expertise.
And so across that range
there's an opportunity
for customers to really
be able to leverage
the power of Google AI in
almost every business problem
they face.
And that can be very exciting.
And it can be a
little bit daunting
if you don't know exactly
where to get started.
And so we are offering
a number of solutions,
through things like our
professional services
organization.
For customers who aren't
sure where to start,
we can help them.
And then we have
a series of demos
of tools, all kinds
of information
that you can gather
to really help
you figure out where AI can
help make your business better.
SPEAKER 1: So as the
Director of AI Strategy,
is there anything
you can tell us
about what we can look
forward to in the near future?
TRACY FREY: That's
a great question.
So I think what's top of mind
for me is all of the ways
that we can make AI easier
for companies to use.
How we can help them
scale their businesses.
And so we are
spending a lot of time
in really building that ease of
use into everything we offer.
Another area that you will
likely start to see from us
is continuing our efforts
around explainability.
So I really firmly believe
that in order for AI
to be successful it
really has to be trusted.
And in order for
it to be trusted
it has to be built and deployed
and thought of responsibly.
And part of that is
about understanding
what is in those
machine learning models
and how they're
making decisions.
And so we have a lot of exciting
efforts around explainability
and interpretability.
SPEAKER 1: Also, trust is such
an important feature in all
of the things that we do.
TRACY FREY: That's right.
SPEAKER 1: Tracy, thank
you so much for helping
us understand the power
of AI to improve our work.
TRACY FREY: You're so
welcome, glad to be here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]